You gonna move
I haven't decided see that's what I'm worried
about the fury I knew was always three steps ahead
if I remember correctly you called me
pontalos's request your lack of contact over the
past few years sent a pretty clear message meaning
you're not ready for this Fury there's a very
real threat out there you were never the same
after the blip you always told me there is no
shame in Walking Away when the steps are uncertain
so check your footing otherwise
someone's gonna get hurt
that invasion is here Odie and here's the crazy
part we can't even tell who the Invaders are
why haven't you called any of
your special friends this war is
alone
this world is burning and it is you who lit the match
this is personal
you're the most wanted man
on the planet
Well, Momma always said I was special
experience the six episode event join
me in the extinction of the human race
you got to figure out which
side you're on
Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie Marvel dropped a bunch of new secret
Invasion footage so we'll break it all down
I'm doing videos for all the episodes be sure
to subscribe to get them all because they start
pretty soon the first big scene is from episode
one it's basically Nick Fury explaining the
Avengers end game aftermath like what happened
why did you disappear on the space station for
so many years it's been about three years since
Avengers endgame at least they might explain
during the episode the timeline is just a little
bit different than that but it's close to about
three years because this is after the events of
Spider-Man no way home most of the Marvel movies
in the Disney plus series are meant to move in
relative real time like one right after the other
as they are released in real life but there are a
few exceptions to that like the eternals movie
which jumps around in the timeline but the idea
is that Nick Fury was like it was really him
during Iron Man's funeral in Avengers end game
after he died he had no idea what to do like the
blip left him completely shaken Thanos everything
that final battle all the time travel like he
never predicted any of that stuff in his previous
bottles he does the decree and other big threats
from outer space could be coming that's why they
built the space stations starting in the 90s like
they turned the original Marvel's ship into the
larger space station which they're calling the
saber space station now during the series but
I think when we got to the Kang Multiverse War
and the stuff that'll be happening in Avengers
5 Kang Dynasty that's the stuff that he just
absolutely did not predict so the quote Maria
Hill uses about the unsure steps the unsure path
forward is basically him not being sure what to
do so he stepped away so that people wouldn't get
hurt he wouldn't make things worse and could just
try to figure things out and it's just taken
him this long to start figuring things out
the way they're explained during the series he
hasn't created the new version of The Avengers
yet because during some of the other trailers
that they've released people are asking where
are the Avengers why aren't they taking care of
this why aren't they handling these evil Skrulls
that's because Nick Fury hasn't got to that point
yet Samuel L Jackson did say in real life when it
comes time when it comes time to put together
that next Avengers team that's when he'll show
up and put it together it'll be a bit of a
call back to that original Iron Man 1 Post
editing where he started going around putting
together that first Avengers team we're supposed
to get a teaser for that of some kind like we're
supposed to tease the next Avengers team during
Captain America four Brave New World but I
don't think that they're actually going to
show up till we start seeing more Marvel phase
six movies like we met some of the characters
that will be on that next Avengers team in that
shangshi post credit scene is kind of an Avengers
reference because wonks says welcome to the team
he's saying welcome to the Avengers basically but
we won't start seeing characters referencing the
actual Avengers team like hey they're the other
Avengers come join the event like people saying
the word Avengers more often until Marvel phase
six so right after Iron Man's funeral Nick Fury
goes to the saber space station to basically
peace out for a couple years and Talos fills
in for him as the fake Nick Fury all the way
to present day even though they have the funny
scene during Spider-Man far from home with the
Talos in his wife version of Nick Fury and Maria
Hill they've been doing that for years the other
funny thing too is that they just released the
opening scene from episode one with the actual
opening scene I'll link it at the end of this
because I've already done a video about it but
during that another CIA agent played by Barrington
Darren from The Game of Thrones Universe more Game
of Thrones actors coming into the Marvel universe
is telling Everett Ross about the actual secret
Invasion with these evil group of Skrulls like
you need to worry about this this is happening all
over the world we need to contact Nick Fury get
him down from the saber space station in Everett
Ross is trying to get more evidence for him like
if I'm gonna bring him down from the space station
I'm gonna need more than just theories but during
that clip they make it sound like Everett Ross is
the person to get him to come to planet Earth and
during this clip when the real Nick Fury it is
the real version of Nick Fury meeting with Maria
Hill after years of not answering her messages or
coming to planet Earth she makes it sound like
it was Talos who was the person to get him to
come down from the space station not Everett Ross
so either Everett Ross really is a Skrull during
that opening scene or he's just unsuccessful in
getting Nick Fury to come down like Nick Fury kind
of ignores him a little bit at least at first
then playing chess is also a cool reference to
all the chess games that Professor X that Magneto
played over the years Stan Lee also had a cameo
scene in the first Avengers movie at the very
end in Central Park playing chess though which
is also another reference because they did that
during one of the X-Men movies with Magneto in
Central Park playing chess when he got his powers
back we are starting to get X-Men in the MCU both
new ones occurring naturally in the 616 Universe
like the whole Miss Marvel twist with them using
the theme song from X-Men the Animated Series but
also people like Deadpool Wolverine coming from
the fox Marvel Universe like Multiverse explainer
for X-Men as well the reason why they played chess
during the X-Men movies was mostly because they
were friends and it was part of their past time
together like it was a way for them to put down
arms so to speak metaphorically and just come
together as friends like okay we're gonna chill
for a little while and just talk this out over a
game of chess Because by the present day of that
Universe in those movies they become opposing
sides in what to do over the war against mutants
in their Universe the funny thing about Deadpool 3
though the big twist is rumored that they're going
to be visiting a universe like Deadpool goes to a
universe where the X-Men sided with Magneto and
the Brotherhood of mutants instead of opposing
them so they wind up taking over that version
of Earth it is Loosely based on the onslaught
plot where Magneto basically takes over the planet
there are a lot of stories where Magneto winds up
taking over the entire planet like House of them
is another famous example in one of the other big
discussions that's going to happen during the
series is how true to character everyone feels
like Nick Fury piecing out for years and years on
his space station is going to feel like when Nick
Fury actually do that would he not have a play
would he be so dumbfounded by what happened with
the snap in Avengers end game that he wouldn't do
anything for years that's the way they're sort of
tying together the continuity like why they didn't
use Nick Fury in any of the big movies for years
but in real life the funny explainer behind that
is because Marvel had completely different plans
for what it was going to do right after Avengers
end game then the virus happened like that
caused a bunch of delays then they got the X-Men
characters the Fantastic Four characters back with
the fox Disney deal they didn't originally have
plans for that and they didn't originally plan on
Kang being the big villain way back when they were
still working on Avengers Endgame because lighting
actors up like all these big contracts spending
all these millions and millions of dollars like
hundreds of millions of dollars takes so much work
they usually plan about five years in advance so
like right now Kevin foggy has loose plans for
what they're doing into Marvel phase 7 after
Avengers Secret Wars whether or not that winds
up being two movies but years ago when they were
still developing Avengers end game like before
they'd finished filming it when they were still
trying to figure out what their path for was
going to be after Marvel phase 3. the fox Disney
deal hadn't become a thing so he couldn't plan on
using the X-Men like he didn't know that he was
going to be able to use them so we had to develop
a completely separate plan without mutants and if
you remember reading a lot of stories from back
then originally the plan was going to turn on the
eternals characters originally like way back
years ago before they knew they'd get all these
characters back from the fox Marvel Universe
they originally planned for a lot of Marvel
phase four five and six to turn on the eternals
characters just in general in the celestials even
though there's been so much chaos in the
Marvel Universe in the past several years
I think things wind up working in their favor
because the response to the eternals movie was
so divided can you imagine them trying to launch
an entire era of Marvel based on the original
eternals movie as it existed there's some good
things going on during that I'm really excited
about what they could do with kit Harrington's
Black Knight character in the celestial characters
just in general but I think originally they'd
planned for the eternals to be the replacement
in the MCU for the mutant characters even though
it would have been so much easier if they'd
originally known that they'd always get the X-Men
and they could just plan for that that's actually
one of the reasons why you're not seeing a ton
of X-Men stuff till much much later like they
had to change their plans once they did get the
characters back and sort of fold them into the
five-year plus plan that they'd already made like
all these contracts and all these movies they'd
already green lighted right now the plan is to
use Avengers Secret Wars or at least one of the
secret Wars movies if they do wind up doing two
of them as a swan song for The Legacy characters
which will be after 2025 big coincidence then
after they fixed the Multiverse during Secret
Wars and things go relatively back to normal
they change things that explains how they can
recast some of the actors inside the MCU in those
original versions of the characters go back to
their original universes with a few of them like
Deadpool for example staying in the regular MCU
Universe the way they're doing this series is a
little bit smaller scale and it's more like the
Winter Soldier like the Thriller mystery aspect
with them going around trying to find what's
going on with this secret plot of the Skrulls so
even though there's a lot of space based stuff
like Skrulls outer space you're talking about
going on during this and it'll connect with
the Marvels movie which is very space-based most
of the secret Invasion episodes are meant to set
up the dark reign of Marvel on planet Earth like
relatively earth-based plot during Marvel phase
5. so there won't be as much Kang stuff going on
during this like the Kang Multiverse War plot as
there would during a series like Loki season
2 which will be coming in October let me know
in the comments if you spotted any other Easter
eggs during these clips and footage that I didn't
talk about in the video in my secret Invasion
episodes we'll start really soon so be sure to
enable alerts for my channel so you don't miss
that everyone click here for that full opening
scene from episode one and click here for my brand
new Spider-Man 4 and live action Miles Morales
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!